[Music]
officials in cities across the country
are urging calm as we await the release
of body cam video from Memphis that is
said to be pretty brutal
a horrific beating of Tyree Nichols that
later led to his death the police chief
calling the footage horrifying and
disgusting all five Memphis officers
involved have been arrested and charged
with second-degree murder and other
felonies the incident happening earlier
this month on January 7th when 29 year
old Tyree Nichols was pulled over for a
suspicion of reckless driving an initial
confrontation occurred between the
officers and Nichols he then fled the
scene and later a confrontation happened
and the officers arrested Nichols he
went to the hospital with serious
injuries and died three days later on
January 10th
the following week Memphis Police
launched an investigation as did the doj
by January 20th those five officers were
fired and were arrested yesterday
cities are preparing for unrest but
Tyree Nichols mom is pleading the
supporters to protest peacefully
but I want each and every one of you
in peace
I don't want us burning up our cities
tearing up the streets because that's
not what my son stood for that's right
and if you guys are here for me and
Tyree then you will protest peacefully
you can get your point across but we
don't need to tear up our cities people
because we do have to live in them and
the Memphis police chief is emphasizing
that this is not about race
it takes off the table that issues and
problems in law enforcement is about
race and it is not it's about human
dignity Integrity accountability and the
duty to protect our community
so Jessica we've heard of victims
families before in these situations
plead for calm plead for peace and
oftentimes those fleas are not followed
how do you think things are going to
shake out tonight well I'm hopeful that
they will he the family's calls
President Biden released a statement as
well saying please be peaceful about
this but the timing is difficult it's
going to come out after 7 pm on a Friday
night and I can see both sides to this
that maybe it's better if people are
going to protest that you have the
weekend where you're not supposed to be
at work but it also could be extremely
dangerous people running around you I
mean you're sitting at home on a Friday
night at 7 30 and you see a video like
that it's it's got to be pretty bad if
they preemptively charge them to make
sure that everyone knew that it was this
bad if they're saying that it's arguably
worse than the Rodney King video
and we know
um that there are people the five police
officers a firefighter who responded to
the scene as well has also been charged
um I think that we're in for a really
heart-wrenching weekend and few days
after that and I'm honestly scared I'm
scared also to personally watch the
video I watched the George Floyd video
which was very difficult and it sounds
like this is going to be worse than that
which is hard to imagine judge how do
you think the Memphis Police Department
and the authorities down there have
handled the situation so far they got
out in front of it Jesse and they
charged as you said the murder in the
second degree along with you said other
felonies we're talking about kidnapping
as well as every possible crime they've
been charged with my understanding is
that the D.A is well respected there
and that the governor along with uh the
mayor in that town have worked well with
the community and you may recall that
even during the George Floyd uh riots
Memphis was relatively quiet I like
everyone at this table and I'm sure in
America is just kind of holding uh my
breath hoping that it's not as bad uh as
they say it is the truth is we already
know it's worse than Rodney King Rodney
King didn't die uh but what we've got is
a family here who's got a great deal of
dignity saying please don't destroy the
city but what I also know is that for
the last several years in this country
there has been an effort to defund the
police not just an effort it's a reality
to defund and demoralize the police when
Tim Scott came out with a police Reform
Bill nobody even wanted to read it we
talk about police training and that's
what's going to come out of this they're
going to be prosecuted as well they
should if everything that's being said
it comes out to be the case but we've
got to recognize that just this past
week we talked about that Atlanta public
safety they were trying to build a new
building for training and they came
antifa I don't know who it was came out
of the woods and started shooting at the
police we need more police training we
have to recognize that these cops are
bringing shame on everyday cops who go
out there and risk their lives they're
bringing shame on the community and
they're bringing shame on the black
community as well and that's not that's
not who we are and so we've got to
prepare to bring the toughest punishment
if indeed it is what we expect it to be
and as it relates to the issue of when
is the best time to bring it out I
thought that a Monday morning at eight
o'clock might be the best time to let
this out so did I but this is what
they're saying Jesse they're saying that
people will be at work kids will be at
school now people will be home I
understand they're ready to impose a
curfew and to shut everything down so
maybe it's the right time this is the
police chief addressing the timing of
the release let's watch that
we think about the entire public to tell
you truth we thought about schools we
thought about business and we felt like
Friday afternoon if there were
individuals decided they wanted to
peacefully protest at least other
individuals would have you know gone
home schools would be out and it
wouldn't be as disruptive as it would
have been if we released it on a
Wednesday afternoon
Brian Well I this is going to be an
interesting study because
um the one thing you don't want is what
happened in Chicago you find out eight
months prior there was this horrible
video it was suppressed and it comes out
and he goes well you're trying to hide
okay no matter what your story is if
you're a police officer you're gonna
have a hard time getting ahead of this
because it seems like you suppressed it
I could I on the surface this just seems
like a bad move what we're getting
coming into the show last night we're
watching the press conference with the
police officers and they're saying this
is one of the worst things they've ever
seen stay tuned for tomorrow night I
mean it's almost as if they're queuing
up our programming the beginning of your
show and getting everyone ready now one
way you could say is at least kids won't
be in school they don't have to cut
school I don't know what the point of
that is but the other thing I'm thinking
of now everyone is off whether it's most
people are off they're off from work
they're off from school we've had
they've had time to get into their place
they've got a time to coordinate and
even though the president United States
says that you go ahead and protest but
make it peaceful my feeling is that
people have had so long to get in place
and think about it we're all ready for
something horrific that we're kind of
setting ourselves up to see things burn
if this does work this is the new
template but I just I was texting with
Ben jealous who the former head of the
NAACP and I said what do you think and
he said if the if the leaders the civil
rights leaders and the clergy are out
ahead of time over the last 48 hours
talking to all the people and activists
there won't be a problem and he said
remember George Zimmerman they did not
have an out of control riot in Sanford
because all the clergy not the cops
because you're out there saying guys not
a good time to burn down the city make
your point this way so my hope is to use
this time for the AL sharptons and the
other civil rights leaders to get in
place and tell them don't burn down the
city it's going to hurt them hurt the
message do you think the fact that the
racial Dynamic is different in this case
those were five black officers the
victim is black does that change
anything on the ground
I don't know the answer to that um and I
think that's a good
opportunity Jesse to remind people that
this hour right this minute 508 PM
Eastern there is a whole lot more about
this case and this incident that we
don't know than we do know there's a lot
of questions that are outstanding I
think the video will probably speak to
some of those when it comes out in two
hours from now we don't know exactly
what prompted the initial and then the
second pullover by police officers that
night we don't know what the officer
said to one another we don't know what
they said to Tyree we don't know what he
said to them we don't know what his last
words were yet
um all this will be
hopefully illuminated at least in part
when we get the information at seven I
will say to Brian's point about the
rollout for lack of a better word of
this video I mean there's no good time
to do anything like this
um it is notable that the wheels of
Justice are already in this case turning
faster than they have in previous cases
there's not been a cover-up does it
bother you don't have the cops of a
perspective at all I mean it looks
overwhelming I get it but don't we need
both sides well evidently Elite cops
these weren't just fresh out of the
academy no but they had a record
question for being extremely aggressive
we're going to get their body cam video
we'll know what they said and then they
will also have their day in court when
the cases but they're also Street crime
we're dealing with a different breed of
cop this is the cop who goes in the city
this is the copper grabs the guns the
drugs I mean these are these are roofer
cups not the sense that they're
violating the law but they are in the
face of criminals every minute they
usually know the names of the people in
the neighborhood and where to go yeah
all right so we'll find out more after
seven o'clock so stay with Fox for that
and we'll continue to monitor that
situation hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else